i think many 60 symbols viewers will
know that once you get down to the
quantum level the atomic molecular the
single particle level you've got to
start taking in this weird and it is
weird
characteristic that particles start to
behave like waves it's not to say they
are waves but they start to have wave
light characteristics it's sort of
obvious that there are going to be
natural links to other waves and in
particular sound waves because what's
music music is just sound waves and this
is how different sound waves interact
different resonances different notes etc
how those different frequencies play
together and play off each other
[Music]
the first time people come across the
uncertainty principle is the idea of um
position and momentum that if we know
the position of something with a certain
accuracy we have less accuracy in
measuring its momentum
and vice versa and now often that is
painted as a problem with the
measurement
but it's not a problem with the
measurement it's just fundamentally due
to the properties of waves what i'm
going to do now is hit the string and
just take my hand away and let's listen
to what what happens you know what's
going to happen
so the note lasts for a long time
there's quite a lot of distortion on it
so it'll take quite some time to decay
off but i'm not touching it and it's
just coming to a natural end to its
vibration just in terms of how the
energy is dissipated
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
do what all good metal guitarists do and
instead of just letting the note ring
out like that i'm going to damp it with
the palm of my hand
so i'm going to put it on the bridge and
now when i hit the guitar you're going
to get that classic metal chug
[Music]
just like that just
so you're denying it the opportunity to
continue vibrating yes exactly i'm
denying it the opportunity to keep
vibrating and so we've got the key
difference here not a very subtle
difference we've got a difference
between a note that extends for a long
period of time and a note that's what we
say is time limited just simply as
technical language to say that it just
lasts a short amount of time right so
the question now is when we look at the
frequency spectrum of these notes what
do they look like so we can we can look
at the the wave in time
and we can look at it in frequency and
before we look at the the frequency
spectrum of that let's look at a really
simple example and this is almost an
example you could do at home we just
whistle a note
whistle it for a long time now
interestingly a whistled note is about
as close to a sine wave as you're going
to get this is how its amplitude varies
its time and it looks pretty much like a
pure sine wave and then if we look at
its frequency we convert this from time
on this axis to frequency in this axis
then we get a sharp spike because it's
only one sine wave it's only one pure
frequency say for want of argument it's
middle c now if i whistle middle c
and you play middle c and piano
or you play middle c in guitar
then clearly our ear can detect the
difference but yet it's still the same
note
so what is it about the waveform that
means our ear and our brain obviously
can determine the difference because
this is classically this is how we're
always told this is what waves like look
like they're the sine wave it's very
straightforward if you've got a lone
then you've got a small number of
vibrations per second if you've got a
high note ah then you've got a large
number of vibrations per second but it's
there's obviously got to be something
more to it than that because if that's
all there was to it then every note
would sound like a whistle and so if we
whistle you know at different
frequencies then what will happen is
that the note will move around the
frequency move around i think many of
you know this but if we look at a guitar
string it's a lot more complicated than
a sine wave and that's because
when we look at the frequency spectrum
of this many different frequencies
contribute to give you that sound that's
how your ear determines the difference
because your ear can hear all those
different frequencies and how they
interact and it's that that gives you
the time of the note where am i going
with this let's take that really
distorted guitar sound now that's a lot
more complicated than either a whistle
or an undistorted guitar so you might
expect that its frequency spectrum might
look fairly complicated so we take that
long note and play it
[Music]
that's what it looks like in time and if
we take a frequency spectrum it's a
fairly you can hear it it's a fairly
what we'd say is harmonically rich sound
and you get all these different
harmonics it's a bit like looking at a
house that's been made of bricks or
stones you'd say both of them are a
house but they look completely different
that's exactly it that's precisely it
yeah it's just a different way with
different representation of the data the
key thing is if you look at those peaks
they're fairly sharp they're fairly
sharp spikes let's just zoom in on one
of those picks just one of those
particular harmonics and if we look at
that this is what it looks like this is
from our very strong guitar signal the
very distorted guitar signal where we
let the note ring out for a long time
and it looks like this it's very sharp
so here's the key here's the uncertainty
principle you've waited a long time for
this but here's the uncertainty
principle widen time narrow and
frequency
that's it
wide in time narrow frequency i've not
mentioned an observer i've not mentioned
quantum particles i've not mentioned
collapse of wave function i've simply
shown you in the everyday world around
us
this is the uncertainty principle
so because if it's wide in time we've
got a fair amount of uncertainty as to
as to where it is if i let that note
ring out for a long time were uncertain
when did it start when did it end and in
fact if you let that note ring for all
eternity
literally and we do lots of integrals
like this in physics which go from minus
infinity to plus infinity
then this will be infinitesimally narrow
so infinitely wide infinitesimally
narrow but when you chug you're saying
the frequency is less certain precisely
so if we look at this again here's our
long note so what i'm going to do now is
show you the frequency spectrum for the
short note it's the same string i'm
hitting all i'm doing is instead of
letting it ring out for a long time i'm
i'm compressing it in time i'm chugging
don't
and say just that don't and you can
almost hear so actually it's a little
bit more difficult to distinguish what
the tone is there if we look at that in
the frequency spectrum instead of it
being this very sharp peak it's
broadened out and you might think well
that seems really strange why should it
broad now why should you need more
frequencies when fundamentally you're
hitting the same string narrow in time
wide and frequency and you might think
well why is that because it's the same
fundamentally it's the same note but due
to a
brilliant literally brilliant physicist
and mathematician a guy called fourier
for those of you who speak french i
apologize and he told us that
practically any signal or certainly any
signal or any waveform or any pattern
that physicists care about can be
represented by a sum of signs that's it
so you take that really simple sign with
if you add up enough of them and you add
them enough of them in the right way in
terms of changing the frequency and
changing the amplitude and changes
what's called the phase in terms of how
they line up you can produce any signal
to create that signal what we need to do
is add up many more sine waves than to
create the signal where the wave extends
for a long time go back and think about
that whistle that says you've got this
whistle that's lasting for a long time
that's a pure sign tone even if we were
to take that whistle and instead go
we just cut it off and we go
like that so something equivalent to the
chug here what we're going to have to do
to represent that in terms of the
frequencies because we have to represent
that cutoff is we're going to have to
add in new frequencies to the mix
because fourier tells us that any
pattern is a sum of signs so we need
more building blocks to make a short
note because it has a start and then
because it has a start and an end ah
brady can you can you just say that
again because that's what i think it's
that you've reached that realization is
an important thing just say that again
because i think that's you said it
because i thought a short note would
need less information to describe itself
if you've got a sign if if what you're
doing if your basic bloodline block is a
sine wave and you your pattern just
looks like one sine wave and it extends
for all infinity then you've just got
one in the mix if however your basic
building block is a sine wave and it is
and you've got something that no longer
looks like a sine wave because it cuts
off then you have to add more building
blocks but that's really
counterintuitive if you've got a note
that is finite it is not going to have
an infinite testing narrow frequency
spectrum it's going to have a finite
width it will have a finite width
because it's it's in the real universe
we don't have infinities and we don't
have infinitesimal quantities
so any any real note will have a finite
width but the shorter you make that note
and i stress that again this is the
uncertainty principle and shorter you
make that note the wider its frequency
spectrum becomes moreover what you have
is your in one case you've got time and
in the other case you've got frequency
now this is important it's a really it
seems like a um a really trite point but
if more undergraduate students because i
didn't i didn't grasp this until i think
i got to third or fourth year more
undergraduate students got this i think
that it would make
furry analysis and quantum a lot easier
we've got time what's the unit of time
seconds what's the unit of frequency
hertz one over seconds
so they're inversely related so you know
if you've got uh you've got seconds and
you've got seconds to the minus one so
it sort of makes sense that if you widen
in one domain you're going to narrow in
the other domain because time and
frequency inversely related a good way
to think of it is that frequency is
reciprocal time because what we're about
to get on to is space and reciprocal
space
because i don't see how this relates to
a particle's position and momentum
so that's exactly where we're going now
so you've got that we've got we've
covered this idea of frequency and time
how does that relate to position and
momentum well let me introduce this
wonderful band called striper why the
hell am i bringing up striper well what
i want to do is focus on these stripes
so what we have here is a pattern that
repeats in space what is this
representing what could it be it could
be you know you could see these periodic
patterns everywhere around us and
particularly you know you look at carpet
you look at wallpaper those are tiling
patterns there's a periodicity there
there's a repeating unit it could be
spandex pants and it could be spandex
pants so we can work out very easily
what the repeat period is let's see
argument it says 23 centimeters and
what's the repeat so the repeat unit
here is there to there so that's nine so
in terms of our period in space we've
got nine centimeters let's put that
period and we put a little s
to represent space so that's our spatial
period we can write down a spatial
frequency which is how many of these do
we get per meter and we let's let's be
good and let's convert this to meters so
our spatial frequency is going to be 1
over
0.09 meters and that's going to have
units meters to the minus 1. this is
units meters this is units meters minus
1. our whistle had unit seconds and our
frequency spectrum had units seconds to
the minus 1. time reciprocal time space
reciprocal space once we've got a wave
in space we can write down a particular
spatial frequency we can have a spatial
frequency which is relatively low or
spatial frequency which is relatively
high how does this finally connect with
quantum and it's exactly the same idea
now if i in terms of the uncertainty
principle if i have a wave in space and
i can press that wave in space so it's
it's not extending for a long time it's
not repeating then i will
correspondingly have a broader spatial
frequency spectrum
right how the heck does that come into
quantum mechanics the way it comes into
quantum mechanics is this momentum is
equal to planck's constant over
wavelength right but notice that it's
over wavelength
it's one over wavelength which means it
must have units meters to the minus one
so another way of of of thinking about
momentum is that momentum is spatial
frequency it's the number of repeats in
space and so you've got a particle which
is a higher frequency will have a higher
momentum in terms of its quantum wave if
that quantum wave is a higher frequency
it will have a higher momentum and that
that's where the link comes we're
talking about waves it doesn't matter if
they're waves and time or waves in space
the uncertainty principle isn't this
magic formula that's been plucked out
because of quantum
because everything's quantum it's
fundamentally due to waves and it
doesn't matter if we look at the waves
in the quantum regime or in the
classical regime in the world around us
it's the same physics so the brownly
tells us that we've got this inverse
relationship between momentum and
wavelength how does that in turn relate
to the uncertainty principle which tells
us about position and momentum tells us
that the the the more accurately we know
the position the less accurately we know
the momentum the important thing here is
that
again it's an inverse relationship it's
just like the relationship frequency
frequency and time it's that one is the
inverse of the other so if you compress
if you know something more accurately in
space in terms of momentum it broadens
out momentum uncertainty is broader in
momentum it's exactly the same as when
we had that whistled note when that was
a node extends for a long time which
means that if you think about that
instead of time now you think of it in
space you think about your particle
extending for a long time it means
you've got a massive amount of
uncertainty in knowing where that
position is but if you think about it in
terms of reciprocal space which as the
brownie shows us is directly related to
momentum it's incredibly well known it's
a single spike and vice versa what are
the building blocks with all our atoms
and things what a beautiful question
brady they're exactly the same it's
exactly the same furry analysis we're
doing the build-up it doesn't matter if
we're talking about musical notes or
quantum mechanical particles it's waves
it's waves and therefore we use the same
type of analysis we use furry analysis
well there's the question the
probability waves and quantum mechanics
the probability was and in fact do we
know truly there are like 25 different
interpretations of what those waves
actually mean we don't know that that's
a big unanswered question in quantum but
we know the waves and in fact we can do
these experiments we can build up
effectively little guitar strings with
atoms and we can look at how the
electrons are arranged in those and they
are literally arranged as in guitar
strings
so with the music example at the start
of this video
the building blocks were sound waves
they were you know
compression of air yeah with atoms and
momentum and things like that there are
waves of somethingness that we don't
understand the waves that well we have
something in quantum mechanics called
the wave function and we can build that
wave function up just as we build up
different sound waves we can build up
different wave functions for a system by
adding in different sine waves when we
square that and we square it in a
particular way
then what we get is a probability wave
and so yes there are things we don't
understand but what we do know and this
is important sometimes quantum is seen
to be well the scientists don't really
know what's going on everything's weird
some things are weird but an awful lot
we do understand and we can do the maths
and we can treat those those particles
in terms of wave-like properties and it
works beautifully we get these
incredible analogs to the sound of our
very heavily distorted guitar
thanks for watching this video for more
phil
physics and heavy metal music why don't
you check out his new book
this is it
when the uncertainty principle goes to
eleven it's out now illustrations by
pete mcpartlin who also does a lot of
the animations here on 60 symbols also
check out phil in a recent episode of my
podcast the unmade podcast in it phil
throws around a few ideas of his own for
podcasts including one called when
scientists go to seed which is all about
well when scientists start having a few
loopy ideas that maybe they shouldn't
check it out there are links on the
screen and in the video description did
you ever used to dress like this i
didn't dress like this no i was more of
the thrash metal brigade i wasn't quite
of the hair metal i'm immensely follow
follicly challenged now but it's always
the case
look at the picture on the screen